l'invité du jour l'invité du jour c'est
vous Bruno fucks bonjour bonjour membre
du MoDem député du Haut-Rhin vous
déposez une proposition de loi contre
les démarchage abusif au CPF le fameux
compte personnel de formation on a tous
reçu ces appels CSMS ces mails parfois
insistant je le disais c'est
insupportable on va y revenir dans un
instant pour une fuz j'ai d'abord une ou
deux questions d'actualité l'imamic
youssem arrêtez hier en Belgique Gérald
Darmanin s'en réjouit ce matin il a été
repéré localisé par la police française
à Mons juste à la frontière il devrait
être renvoyé en France dans les
prochains jours j'allais dire enfin
Bruno Fuchs ça fait plus d'un mois que
le feuilleton traîne
oui enfin je pense que tu as un retour à
la normale il y a arrêté d'expulsion et
puis depuis qu'il a fui en réalité ses
responsabilités puisqu'il a refusé de
d'assumer les discours de de haine
antisémite et notamment de discours
d'infériorité de la femme puisqu'il a il
a fui enfin c'est un retour à la normale
je pense c'est un retour aussi qui
marque la détermination de la lutte
contre l'islam politique et puisque je
vous parle de Mulhouse qui est une ville
dans laquelle nous avons 130
nationalités de très fortes communautés
musulmane surtout dire que il s'agit là
d'un individu ils sont peu nombreux
identifiés pour la plupart et qu'il ne
faut pas faire d'amalgame c'est-à-dire
que ce que je cherche cette imam c'est
maintenant à avoir une position de
victime mais en même temps c'est un
message envoyé à d'autres prédicateurs
qui pourraient se trouver à Mulhouse
c'est ce que disait l'imam Hassan
chalgummy imam de Drancy ce matin sur
RMC en disant l'État français en
arrêtant x youssen envoie aussi ce
message que tôt ou tard la justice les
rattrape à d'autres prédicateurs
exactement mais surtout je pense que je
cherche cette image cette à se rendre
victime en médiatisant effectivement ça
fuite on arrestation il va vouloir faire
un amalgame avec une partie importante
de nos compatriotes de confession
musulmane ici je le vois tous les jours
nous avons des millions de musulmans qui
vivent leur foi tout en étant très bien
intégré dans les valeurs de la
républiqueurs il faut mettre un terme
assez actions d'Islam politique de
séparatisme mais il s'agit d'une partie
très
minoritaire de la population ici
présente en France la suite voulu par
Gérald Darmanin c'est qu'il soit
désormais expulsé renvoyé vers le Maroc
sauf que le Maroc n'en veut plus donc il
va falloir aussi régler ce même la Bruno
Fox sinon c'est au moins un demi
camouflé pour le ministre de l'intérieur
c'est que nous avons effectivement une
partie importante des personnes qui sont
expulsées que leur pays d'origine ne
veut pas recueillir donc on a un effort
diplomatique à faire de façon plus large
avec le Maroc avec la Tunisie avec
l'Algérie avec d'autres pays qui avec
lesquels on a effectivement commencé et
le ministre en particulier a commencé un
bras de fer pour que il puisse
accueillir ces prédicateurs
oui la pression ou des discussions plus
plus contributives c'est pas forcément
un rapport de force je pense qu'il faut
que chacun voit son intérêt on ne peut
pas nous en France accueillir des
personnes qui ne sont pas dans les
valeurs de la République et même si nous
sommes en démocratie il faut qu'on ait
des procédures simplifiées pour pouvoir
les renvoyer on peut pas avoir des
procédures qui durent éternellement de
façon à ce que ces personne ne reste pas
sur le territoire français
plus constructives à mon avis Bruno faut
que j'en viens au CPF votre dossier
appel intempestif qui nous pousse à
utiliser l'argent de notre compte
personnel de formation la plupart du
temps ce sont des arnaques jusqu'à 43
millions d'euros
d'arnaque évoquent Bercy que
proposez-vous pour y mettre fin
alors la mesure la plus forte et
identifiée c'est une mesure
d'interdiction pure et simple de
démarchage
sous toutes ses formes directement des
titulaires de CPF on ne nous appellerait
plus on ne recevrait plus de mails ou de
SMS concrètement comment ça peut marcher
si si vous avez certainement recevoir
encore pendant un certain temps sauf que
le fait de vous démarcher devient
purement illégal et donc pas sous le
coup de la loi donc comme vous recevez
le premier message c'est quand vous
recevez un SMS ou un appel ou un
courriel vous savez que cette démarche
là est illégale donc vous n'avez plus de
doute dans votre esprit sur la légalité
de la démarche ça c'est la chose la plus
importante
on a deux types de sanctions on a une
sanction et c'est ça que renforce la loi
également ou la précise on a une
sanction qui est administrative
immédiatement la société ou la personne
qui ferait ça tombait le coût de la loi
jusqu'à 375 000 euros d'amende ça c'est
une amende administrative
assez dissuasif et ça n'empêche pas
derrière des poursuites pénales si vous
tombez sous le coup de de la loi cette
fois-ci en terme de poursuite pénale
donc mais là vous avez une amende
immédiate donc je pense ça va dissuader
un grand nombre d'opérateurs de procédés
de la sorte ça ne va pas éliminer les
sms je pense qui vient souvent en plus
Bruno fuck on s'en rend compte quand on
décroche parce que voilà parfois il y a
des numéros on décroche et c'est encore
le CPF et on se rend compte que c'est
pas forcément des entreprises très
organisées derrière que ce sont des
individus qui essayent ici ou là il y a
un autre problème c'est sur les réseaux
sociaux je vois de plus en plus
d'influenceurs twitch TikTok Instagram
faire des stories qui proposent
d'utiliser notre CPF directement en
ligne
oui mais là également nous avons rajouté
en commission un amendement important
qui vise à élargir justement le champ
d'action au réseau sociaux et donc ces
influenceurs s'il interpelle directement
sur la question du CPF peuvent être
également eux aussi
incriminer et sanctionner on voit bien
qu'il s'agit là pour la plupart
d'entreprises
très organisées qui vise ils le font sur
le CPF mais ils peuvent le faire aussi
sur d'autres sujets la carte Vitale par
exemple et donc il faut mettre un terme
à une organisation
criminelle en tant d'escroc
internationaux qui ont trouvé là une
sorte de martingale et qu'ils n'ont rien
à voir avec la formation professionnelle
pour la plupart sont des plateformes
d'appel qui visent à essayer de trouver
des prospects et
des comptes de formation j'entends votre
détermination à brunofucks votre le
texte a été approuvé en commission cette
semaine il serait étudié la semaine
prochaine en hémicycle le tout c'est que
la loi soit appliquée derrière et que
réellement on est de moins en moins ce
genre d'appel et de mails vous avez
alors
la loi la loi doit être appliquée mais
quand vous avez un feu rouge il y a des
gens qui ne s'arrêtent pas au feront-ils
donc l'idée c'est de baisser massivement
l'incitation de ces escrocs à le faire
et ensuite il faut que la Direction
Générale de la Concurrence la
consommation la pression des fraudes et
les moyens et ça c'est pas un sujet
législatif ça c'est un sujet de
l'administration de budget de moyens
pour aller poursuivre justement les
contrevenants
dans le bureau de Gabriel Attal le
ministre du Budget merci à vous pour une
offre député MoDem du Haut-Rhin merci
d'avoir été avec nous merci bien sur RMC